okay so
um i want to start by asking you um
a couple more things about symbolic
thinking because i'm trying to
understand this better and um i'm trying
to
explain it to others and discuss about
it and sometimes i'm
having some difficulties so um
there's a couple of things one of them
is um
how do you validate symbolic thinking
how do you
make sure that you're not just
fantasizing or or
letting your mind wander and you're
actually
thinking in symbols
how how can you tell well there are a
few things
one is the direction in which the
symbolism is pointing
which is that if you're looking at
symbolism and you're trying to find a
pattern
of how things are laying themselves out
then already there's less of a chance
of you being in the wrong
you know compared to when you're trying
to find out
this figure in the revelation you know
which emperor does it represent or with
you know
when when there's that the type of
symbolism i'm talking about is not the
type of symbolism that is a one-for-one
symbolism that is
you know where you have an image kind of
like um
a good example of that would be let's
say c.s lewis where c.s lewis
has a lion aslan and that lion
represents jesus
right so that's not true symbolism i
mean there there is some true symbolism
let's say
and maybe in the way he uses it but
that's not true symbolism in the sense
that
true symbolism is based on the qualities
of the thing itself
and how they come together how you know
how you know that something is something
how you know that it
has unity um and the way that it lays
itself out that's when you start to see
so you actually have to trust the thing
itself like
you have to trust the story itself most
symbolism can be found
let's say you're reading a fairy tale
you you look at the pattern of the fairy
tale the elements within the fairy tale
and you try to to not go outside
right at the beginning you try to just
look at the pattern
like who are the main characters what
are they doing what what what are they
how do they interact and then you start
to try to see if there
is an if there are analogies with other
other stories other patterns other other
places because
one of the ways you validate symbolism
is that you try to see the pattern at
different levels of reality at the same
time
so does the pattern apply to the
individual reality does it apply to
a community does it apply to a nation
you know um
because the notion of symbolism is that
it's a fractal structure
like a tree where the main pattern is
reproduced at every level of reality
okay
okay so um i'm i'm getting a
master's degree in philosophy now i'm a
software developer
actually but i i've started a master's
in
philosophy last year and we've studied
uh semiotics i think
the word in english is not helpful to
understand symbolism or is just
so in my perception semiotics is i don't
know
if i'm explaining this right but tends
to be more analytical and left brain and
symbolism
is more uh right brained or more
intuitive or
something like this i don't know so
so yeah so so symbolism would be more
on the indeed it would be more on the
intuitive side
where you would have you grasp things
you
see that usually you can experience
symbolism in the moment where
you see something um you see something
in in its multiplicity and then
and then the unity of it jumps in your
face i always use the example of
let you know you meet someone you
haven't seen for a very long time
um and then you're talking with them but
you don't know who they are right away
and all of a sudden you recognize them
all of a sudden the face of that person
will change in your perception they'll
actually change
the it'll be it'll change from the face
of a stranger to the face of a person
you know
and that's the experience of symbolism
it's the experience
of seeing a pattern in in multiplicity
and it coming together
so it feels like insight it feels like
you have insight into the world when you
experience that
kind of symbolic pattern i've also heard
you
talk about um symbols being um
participatory or you need to participate
into the symbol can you
can you detail that as a little more
into
how how can i actually participate into
this because okay so the i denote it the
idea is
that symbolism or the way that i talk
about symbolism
is really just the way reality presents
itself to you
that is we tend to think like you talked
about semiotics we tend to think
of interpretation where you have a text
and then you're outside the text and
you're interpreting the text and you're
applying interpretation rules to the
text now
symbolism is is complicated is more not
complicated it's
it's more holistic in the sense
that you are made of the same pattern as
the text you're interpreting
that you are not outside of the pattern
you're inside the pattern
and so you have to be careful you know
to
to think that you're just this strange
object you know objective
uh observer that's outside of space and
time and that is just looking at reality
symbolism understands that you are you
are a part of the world
and that there's nothing wrong with
recognizing the
the anthropic uh shape of the world that
is that the world has a
has the shape of man that the universe
presents itself
through consciousness through a human
experience and that it has the shape of
man
until now what we've been told is that
subjective
right that you have a subjective
experience but that's
the wrong way of looking at it it's not
subjective it's
it's personal in the sense that you have
to experience the world through
consciousness but it's not subjective
it's it can be very much
objective because we experience the same
things in
very similar manners right the the fact
that there are patterns which manifest
themselves
at different and different scales of
reality the fact that
the fact that there's a there's it's not
a it's not like a one-on-one rule but
most people will react the same to a
burn
that's a universal reality it's not
subjective you know it's not subjective
in the sense of relative
it's objective but it's experienced
personally
and so that's what i mean by you have to
participate you have to be careful not
to think
that you're an outside observer looking
at the world but that your story
is symbolic and you have to engage
your story your personal narrative in
terms of you as a person
but you also have to engage it within a
community and then within a larger
cosmic story as well
you're a part of the story and uh and so
that's what i mean but when i talk about
how you have to participate
okay okay um can you um
explain how how do you approach teaching
symbol
symbolism well one of the things i joke
about all the time is i say that
the fact that we need to teach symbolism
means we're in a very bad time
the fact that i'm explaining symbolism
it's actually not
good it's actually very bad it means
that it means that we're in a difficult
place
in the sense that we're still part of
the pattern we're still part of the
symbolic pattern
but we're in the let's say if you
imagine the basic pattern of reality
um as a mountain you know like this
cosmic mountain like you see
uh the paradise in scripture is actually
a mountain which people always forget
for some reason
because in ezekiel the paradise is
described as a mountain and so
you have this unity at the top and then
you ha it moves towards multiplicity you
can imagine it as a wheel as well
and so the notion is that the
the pattern is about unity and how it it
kind of
separates into multiplicity that's the
basic pattern so it's the relationship
between unity and multiplicity
now when we have to explain symbolism
it's because we're in the multiplicity
part that is where
we're in the frag we're in danger of
being in the
the fragmentation of the pattern so
we're moving towards death or moving
towards the end
or moving towards you know dissolution
all these
all this type of theory so it first of
all we have to understand that it's a
bad sign
um so the way that you teach it in my
opinion the best way
is to try to create insight in people
is to help have them experience the the
experience of insight
and once you experience insight once you
see like
you know you you have things that you
think didn't think were related then all
of a sudden someone can show you how
they're connected
and can make you experience their their
connection
then that is the best way to get someone
to understand what symbolism is and
hopefully to kind of move forward in
that direction
so that's how i do it and i try to you
know let's say i
let's say i'm talking about a symbolic
structure i always try to do it in a way
that will surprise people
as much as i can so i'll i'll i'll say
something that you think is
that you it makes sense like i'll talk
about a story and
and you'll be like yeah okay i can see
it i can see it and then i'll connect it
to something
which is completely off the map for you
you know connect it to you visiting your
grandmother
and then you'll be like all of a sudden
it'll it'll it'll smash together
and you'll see that this pattern is not
just a arbitrary pattern in a story that
it is actually a pattern of
of reality okay and
can you explain why do you think we're
in this place where we don't understand
symbols anymore
i think uh genoa said that it's because
we're
modern people it's because of modernity
but i'm not sure that well because
well because we're we're definitely
moving toward the end of something
like i i don't know i don't want to be
alarmist but
let's say our civilization our society
has all the signs of uh
of the end like of the end of it and
that means there are different ways of
understanding it
like i said the notion of dissolution
the notion of breakdown
in identity but also a desire to create
very solid identities those two extremes
where you have uh you you have let's say
an emphasis on on migration and
immigration and multiculturalism
and then you have a backlash of purity
and uh nationalism and close borders
you know and so these two extremes as
they're manifesting themselves they
they show you that we are we are
skirting the edge like we're coming
towards the edge just like
a d let's say you imagine a medieval
city just like on the edge of a city
you have both the enemies outside the
gate and then you have the warriors
standing on the
wall with you know with lances and
shields holding out holding them off
those two realities are manifesting
themselves it means we're on the edge
um i don't know if that makes sense it
does yeah
okay and it's not just i use the
example of nations but it's not just the
example of nations it's also
it's also in our you know the whole
notion of sexual identities the the the
breakdown
of society at different levels at the
level of the family at the level of
cities
but also an emphasis on a massive unity
on the idea of global unity or
or you know kind of the notion of trying
to encompass
everything while noticing that
everything is breaking down
at the at the level of communities you
know all those types of extreme
manifestations are
are images of of the end okay
and talking about teaching teaching
symbolism do you use
art to teach symbols or is it related in
any
way of course it's related there there's
there's narrative symbolism and then
there's
visual symbolism you know a visual
version of the patterns and so
i think that art can help you especially
let's say i'm an icon carver that's
my my job i i create icons and so
the iconographic language that the
church developed is a perfect
place to help people see the the
patterns and how
these universal patterns are manifesting
themselves in imagistic form
so i use what i like to do is i like to
to in order to show one of the my
strategies you could say my secret
strategies
has been to propose things which scale
from the highest you know if you think
of let's say
church architecture or um
or icons you know sacred
this notion of the sacred as the highest
form of symbolism but then i also try to
go all the way down into popular movies
or
popular culture uh advertisements
anything
everything participates in that pattern
and so
i i really want to show kind of
everything and so one of the things i've
been talking about a lot is
talking about monsters and hybrids and
marginal marginal things in order to
help people understand
like i tell i'm telling you we're on the
edge of a civilization
and so we see what we're seeing on the
edge of that civilization
are monsters and and craziness and
upside down behavior and hybrids and
mixture and
all the things that happen on the edge
and so i tend to so that's one of the
reasons why i talk about that stuff but
i'm also
always hoping to point you towards the
altar in the middle to point you towards
the center towards the heart towards the
you know the top of the mountain
but we have to talk about what's at the
bottom as well
okay so i wanted to ask you about one of
the symbols that
is a little harder for me to grasp
the symbolistic of community um because
i
know of a couple couple of symbols from
saint paul
talks about uh the community being a
body
uh and in the revelation uh the
community or
the church is the bride uh waiting for
um for christ to return but are there
any other symbols for community or
um how do you
how do you explain community in symbolic
thinking or something like that
well i think i mean saint paul has i
think the best way
let's say from our angle is to
understand the images that are given and
so saint paul gives us an image
but understanding it is different like
seeing it and understanding it is
different so
you could a way to maybe help you
understand the head and the body
is to understand that although we have a
head
and a body everything that exists
has a head and a body okay so everything
that exists
has a place where the identity of that
thing culminates into a point
right so imagine the body also has a
mountain right so there
you have it at the top of the mountain
at the top of the the body you have
the this origin and so everything has
that
because the problem we have is
the problem is always the problem of why
do we think that something is one
that's always the problem which comes to
get comes out is
you know why do we think that a chair is
one thing because the chair is many
things the chair has many
components and colors and aspects and
there are also different types of chairs
how do we know
how do we recognize chair like what is
it that we're able to see that this one
thing
and a lot of people will will think it's
funny because they'll think it's obvious
because it
holds together physically but we can
notice unity in things that don't hold
together physically
we can recognize unity across
like i said across the chairs as well
you can perceive a unity
amongst all the chairs just like you can
perceive the unity of a chair
so that perception of unity how do we
account for it
and that is that is the same thing for
everything that exists in the world and
it's the same thing for a community
which is a community is a negotiation or
a breathing in
and breathing out between unity and
multiplicity
it's it has a community needs to have
multiple
members that are all different from each
other
who are bound together by something
which makes you see that they're also
one and so
that unity could be all kinds of things
it could be that we all play hockey
together
it could be that we you know it could be
that we all live
in a in the same place it could be that
we're the
family we have the same father um and
then ultimately the church itself
shows us the pattern of that which is
that things move into the head
which is the the reason and in the in
the church it's personified as
as christ and that is
the image and so we as the body of
christ we are
multiple but we share in the identity of
christ
and we do that by loving each other
and so the idea of love is the
understanding of the bond which
holds things together but does infuse
them together
so there's a difference between love and
a kind of let's say regimental
uh imposition of view of of uniformity
because the community is not uniform the
community has all different types of
members it has more
smarter people dumber people stronger
people weaker people people who are more
involved people who are less involved
people who are more central to the
community
people who are more kind of on the
margin of the community but there's
something
that which binds them together and that
is
love it's the capacity to be together
without without destroying the
multiplicity without destroying the
difference between things
and then ultimately then that becomes
the image of god himself
because that is the that is why one of
the reasons why christians
have the trinity which is the perfection
of unity and multiplicity
it it is the perfect community god is
the perfect community
perfectly one perfectly multiple and
without contradiction
it seems like a paradox it's funny
because it seems like a total paradox
but it's also it's a paradox but it's
also the pattern of
everything it's the pattern of all
reality all reality has to find balance
between
unity and multiplicity but in god it has
it's perfectly balanced it's
perfectly balanced in a way where
there's abs there's even no distinction
there's no
there's no contradiction between the two
okay so the difference between uh
community
and a group or collectivity is love
love would you say that or love and
there's
there's there's love and there's also
the fractal structure that i'm telling
you about
because one of the difference between
let's say we can you it's
it's it's easy to see it like let's say
you take
uh the traditional catholic church the
way that it was set up okay you could
use anything you
let's just use that because so you have
the you have the church
as a totality you know with its
leadership
and and the people and the parishes and
and uh
not just the parishes but like the
districts and the different dioceses or
whatever
but then the diocese functions the same
way as the whole church
it it has a multiplicity of parishes and
and then there's a there's a let's say
there's an archbishop and then there are
bishops and priests
and then but then a parish
functions the same way as the whole
church too
there's a priest and there's different
people involved there
there are deacons or whatever the way
deacons are old in you i guess
but there are deacons in the church and
there's there's uh
people involved and there's this
multiplicity which manifests itself and
there's a hierarchy of participation
within the church itself just like
there's a hierarchy in the diocese more
some churches are more important
somewhere less et cetera et cetera so
that's how you tell the difference the
modern state what it wants to often do
is it wants to impose from the top
down a kind of uniformity
where there's the state and then there's
all of us right there's
you're french and then everybody speaks
the same language everybody has the same
schooling
it's you know there's this uniformity
and that is not at all
how true community manifests itself
true community manifests itself at every
level and so
there is no competition between the
family
and the church or family and the village
and the village and let's say the larger
nation
there's no competition between these
whereas in the modern
state there tends to be a kind of
top-down imposition and a competition
between
so a desire to eliminate the
intermediary is to have
you know let's say control of the
identity and then uniformity
does that make sense in terms of the
difference between community and a and a
kind of weird
the weird perversion of the modern state
you could say
yeah um i want to ask does this apply to
corporations to
as corporations try to
create a structure like this yeah but i
don't
i won't call it call it a community a
corporation is not a community
no i i don't think well it can be if
they do it
right they could they can have the right
pattern like
if if one of the things that's that
makes
some corporations very successful and be
able to function is that
the the let's say the the head of the of
the company
you know they can't they don't have the
capacity let's say to
enforce everything all the way down and
so they all they have to have a
a kind of aristocracy around them just
like a king they would have a board
or they'll have a you know whatever it
is that the structure of the company and
then
within the company you'll need to have
repetitions of the pattern
all the way down to the the actual
worker in the factory or whatever
and so that the the remainder of ancient
community
is probably what makes corporations work
very well
compared to states also you know
corporations tend to work better than
states
um but in the military you see something
similar too you see
you know a well-ordered military the
general will not
tell the troops to how to dig their
trenches
right the general will give strategy and
then as the
as the orders come down the line of the
hierarchy
then they will become more specific and
each
troop will have its own cohesion and its
own team spirit
you know but that will not compete with
their allegiance to the higher level
and to the to the top so that type of
that type of structure
tends to function really well because it
does mimic let's say
more closely traditional community but
and so let's say like
in an army if in the smaller troops
there's no cohesion between the soldiers
right if there's no love if there's no
bond
the word love it might be a bit strong
but you know that in
the military for example they will do a
lot of things to try to get
the soldiers to bond together at the
level of their of
at the smallest level of the the guys
that are directly around them
you know and that is what that's the
driving force
of the whole army right this bond of the
smaller units
and so you could say the same for for a
traditional community where the families
would be the bond
that hold the kind of hold everything
together and
and then they they also are you know
have allegiance to their clan to the
to the higher identities that's really
cool
okay yeah um about talking about the
structure of the church
isn't there a risk that it could become
bureaucratic
at some point or that there's a
lack of bond of this bond that you've
talked about and
more of a corporation style
administration
yes of course of course there's that
problem there's that difficulty
you know in theory in theory there are
two
let's say one of the reasons why they're
like the two traditions let's say the
two authorities in the church
has been a desire to to prevent
the the fossilization let's say and so
you can imagine that the church just
like in the old testament
has two lines it has a priestly line
and a prophetic line and the priestly
line is there to be more
of a a kind of top-down you know
let's say enforcing power and then the
prophetic line is there to be more of a
a wilder but also a a uh
let's say a more direct version of the
of the pattern and so
and so that's the same thing that
happens in the catholic church for
example you have the
you have the the the authority of the
church but then you also have the saints
and the saints are have more power than
the
than the authority and you see it in the
history of the catholic church for
example where
you know when there were three popes in
avignon
uh they asked catherine of siena who was
this woman who lived in
in a room her whole life and never came
out and was completely isolated that's
her to decide
who the pope was going to be because of
her holy
because she was a holy woman she ended
up having more direct authority than the
than the air then the let's say the the
more
formal structure of the church but you
need both you can't just have one side
if you just have one side you know
either you crystallize the church
crystallizes and it
it it solidifies and becomes like you
said just a kind of cold empty
bureaucracy
or it starts to split and starts to
break apart
and before you know it you have 10
million denominations that all
think that others are heretics so you
you need to have those two sides or else
or else the prophetic side without
without the order side
is like someone drinking too much wine
it doesn't doesn't work it just falls
apart
and do you have an example of a
contemporary church that
has this two forces keeping it together
or
i mean i i think as you know probably i
i converted to orthodoxy i think the
orthodox church has that
um it's a painful it's the thing the
thing is none of it's fun and it's
like human beings are are are not great
and so
it's it still is painful because you see
the conflicts and you see the
you it kind of looks horrible you see
the politics you see the the monastics
who are fighting with the the
church hierarchy the church hierarchy
will will want to sometimes
compromise politically because it's to
their advantage and then the monastics
will be radical and say
like you know you can't do that whatever
so you'll see this tension between
the monastic community and the church
the church hierarchy
but i think in the end if you back off
and you kind of pull away and you look
at the at how it's going in general
it ends up kind of balancing itself out
um
and so not that the orthodox church
isn't in danger right now because
everything's endangered that
you know we're we're in such strange
confused times that
you know it's difficult to avoid it but
i think of all the
the churches it's the one that has
avoided the most
okay uh i wanted to ask a little more
about
uh art and its relation with uh religion
especially uh do you think art can have
a
role in um rejuvenating or
re-empowering religion or reviving it
and i i it depends what you mean what do
you mean by art you mean
like uh let's say do you do
because let's say let's say let's use a
traditional
point of view right so in a traditional
point of view you would have
liturgical art which would be the
architecture the
icons the music of the church all of
that
is it is to me an integral part of what
the church is
you can't you can't get get rid of it
because it's the
it's it's in on the one hand it's the
expression of the pattern it's like the
pattern manifesting itself in
human activity and on the other hand
it's also a guide to help us
know what the proper way
of being and of doing and of making is
you know so it also
actually ends up affecting the way that
we understand making
in the secular in the secular world so
you know i mean it's not
no one would be surprised to understand
to know that church architecture
is was the template for secular
architecture all through
christendom that the church the church
architecture was let's say
the highest form of architecture
and then secular architecture although
it was never like a church
would have the church as its center
right so
a village you have the church in the
middle everybody builds around and so
the the spatial the actual physical
structure of the village ends up being
based on this church it's in the middle
so you can see the same for
uh painting for music
if you look at medieval music for
example and
how music became classical music in the
renaissance and
later you can see that it it still holds
some roots within the medieval structure
within the medieval vocabulary
let's say musical vocabulary um and then
kind of moves away from it but
the the reference is still that and so i
think that
in that's one of the reasons why i'm
doing what i'm doing which is
i think that we have to liturgical art
is
the only real future for art and i say
that
people will think like what a crazy
thing to say in 2020
to say that liturgical art is the future
of art but it's because it's the
template it's because
even though you don't understand even
though you don't know
all the paintings you've ever looked at
are connected to the history of
christian iconography
either reacting to moving away from
referencing
even if you don't know it's all
connected to that
image making it you say even secular
image making is connected to the manner
in which the idea of the precious
painting that you put up on your wall
is directly connected to the notion of
sacred art even if it is a
a moving away from it or a kind of
perversion of that idea
and so to me the it was important just
to
go back and to reconnect and to
rediscover
the sacred language of art not just for
sacred art
but in order to now see the waves
let's say see the waves go all the way
into the secular culture
and i think that that's inevitable um
and if we don't do it it's gonna happen
anyways and i've
been talking about this in several
videos where
people are taking popular culture and
wanting to make it into
sacred art because we have a such a
profound need for it
and so people treat star wars as if it's
a religion treat
harry potter as if it's a religion you
know uh
and you know use let's say someone who
get people get obsessed with like manga
imagery or all this different
or comic book imagery all these
different types of images
and they become iconic to them they they
they see an image of of batman
very close to how they imagine what a
sacred image would be
and so what i what i'd like what i want
people to understand is that if we don't
recover our sacred art of the west and
we don't
let's say recover the inner language of
it it's going to manifest itself in all
kinds of crazy ways
yeah so in my in my church in romania
our
art um is not given
that much importance in my opinion um
and
for example music we don't um compose
that much music
locally here we're just borrowing it
from uh
the states or some other uh composers so
and i i i really think that it would
bring
um more
live than us to the uh the communion of
the
and the meeting of the people here if we
would have
more art and i don't know if that that's
a
true intuition or uh
i mean i i think it would be i think
that
the difficulty in which you're going to
the difficulty you might face is the
difficulty
of certain christian traditions which is
that there are certain christian
traditions
which do not view
do not view the pattern of the
incarnation
as being the pattern of reality and
as infusing everything as being behind
the world
that christ not only is a god you know
was a man in the first century not only
was someone who came to die for your
sins
but is you know the lamb that was slain
before the foundation of the world
that christ is the pattern of everything
he's the divine logos
and so i think that because some people
don't view the world that way
they tend to view the world with a
scientific lens
and then impose on that world vision of
the science this kind of secular
scientific vision
they impose this story of you sinning
and
and adam and eve sinning and then jesus
coming to die and kind of
fixing that problem and and you know now
you now you're saved
and now the purpose of art is to
get other people to be saved yeah right
and so
and so because of that they there's a
lack in the deep
expression of of the logos which appears
in scripture which appears in the image
of the temple in the image all the
the prophetic images that we see are are
soaking in the imagery
of how the logos how the the how the
word of god
ripples through the world and manifests
themselves um and so i think that you're
you're you're always going to kind of
hit that wall a little bit
and and but there are i think there are
ways around it
they're ways around it in the sense that
christianity developed
an extremely powerful language of
architecture
of of music and
of visual language um
and so you know that's the place to look
that's the place to look to kind of
recover it it's just that if you're in a
community that
sees all of that as evil
right and sees all of the tradition the
visual tradition and architectural
tradition and musical tradition
that christians develop for a thousand
years if they see that as evil
then you're going to struggle because
you're going to be grasping as frauds
and you're going to try to
make it up as you go along and you're
going to try to you're going to create
music based on pop music and
all this stuff you know and it's going
to be it's going to have a
a certain weakness yeah that's right
sorry i don't want to be harsh but
that's a that's just that's a difficulty
you know that's one of the reasons why
there's
that's why christian art stinks most of
the time in most christian art that's
made
it's horrible it's it's bad art it's bad
christian art it's just
you know it just doesn't have the depth
that the ancient that you ancient
ancients have
and they also don't have the depth of
the secular people that they're trying
to copy
because they don't understand the actual
message in this
the form of what they're doing so if you
make
jazz has a form you know rock and roll
has a form
that form is symbolic you can't
you can't put a baby to sleep singing
rock and roll songs
and so that's because rock and roll has
a form and that form has an effect on us
and so so there are some things you
can't say or can't do with that form
because it it has a reality of its own
it has its own
it has its own body um and and
that's one of the things that people
tend to ignore they think it's all
arbitrary
and you can just use this form or that
form because it's popular
and and they don't realize it if you use
if you use if you make videos
that you show in church in which you use
advertisement
tropes you're using advertisement
strategies
to make videos to show in your church
then the effect it will have on people
will be the effect that advertisement
has it won't be and you can't
do more than present let's say the
gospel
as a as a commodity that you need to get
if you use those those patterns yeah the
medium is the message
the medium it's not just but yes the
medium is the message you can't
completely go outside of the media okay
okay i have a couple more specific
questions
one is about um symbols in the writings
of saint paul
uh because i've heard sinful being
interpreted in
so many ways like uh universalist and
egalitarian i
i did identitarian stuff like this
um so i was um i was trying to
understand
uh or maybe you can have some references
where i can understand this better
the symbol the symbolic thinking of
saint paul
i mean that's a i can't believe you
asked me this question it's like
saint paul is an ocean to swim in it's
not it's not a it's not as
if saint paul is always saying the same
thing uh
st paul one of the things to understand
about saint paul first of all
is to understand who he is
and what he is in terms of his role
in this the cosmic story you could say
um
and so in the early church there was
this representation
that there were two pillars of the
church
and saint peter was the church of the
gentile sorry saint peter was the church
of the circumcised
and saint paul was the church of the
gentiles
and so in there and you can see early
images where you see
uh saint peter and paul being crowned by
two women who are like these two
churches
um and this is this was still like in
the fifth century they were still
understood that way and so
that's one thing you can understand that
when saint paul
talks he's the letter that he's writing
he's writing them to the people that
he's writing them to
and sometimes he adjusts not a just but
his message
is tailored to the people who he's
talking to
because he says right i'm all things to
all people i'm uh
he saint paul is something of a of a
shape shifter in a way you know um and
so
it's very difficult when people try to
to kind of just skip around in saint
paul it's very difficult
because he's like i said he's saying
different things to different people
um and so it just dip it so
so what is the symbolism that he's
trying to to
i think that i think that saint paul is
mostly trying to emphasize the manner in
which
the outsiders can connect to the heart
and that's mostly what he's he's he is
you know so you you know you have this
image that i told you about you have the
mountain or the wheel with the center
and then he is trying to see how
these outer aspects are connected to the
middle
you know how is it that the foreigner is
if christ is the savior of all if christ
is the divine logos if christ is the
the origin and the culmination of
creation then
how do we deal with this problem of
inside and outside
how do we deal with the problem that
there were jews and gentiles and that
the gentiles were
lost in idolatry how do we deal with
that we have to reconcile that we have
to
join it together um and i think that
that's what he's trying to deal with
okay that's good it's good for in part
but there's so much in st paul saint
paul is saint paul is the greatest
mystic
and and it's so funny because we we've
reduced saint paul so much like
there's so there are some texts in saint
paul that
are just amazing like he he really
is a deep deep profound mystical person
and is speaking about things sometimes
kind of off cut
where he he just says things and he's
referring to all these things in the old
testament you know
um so so he's uh yeah it's difficult
reading st paul is really difficult
and i understand why like all the hair
all the schisms come from saint paul
because he's really hard to read and and
he sometimes he says things
and and uh like i remember when i was
young in church
saint paul would say some things and the
only way the pastor could
could let's say make saint paul
fit in his box as he would say things
like oh he's being sarcastic here
it's like oh really is that what you're
seeing so so you're actually
saint paul says something and so what
you're telling me is that he's actually
saying the opposite of what he's saying
that's some smart hermeneutics huh
pretty smart so you can basically do
whatever you want because every time you
don't agree with what saint paul is
saying you can make him
you can say that he's being sarcastic
he's he's speak he's actually saying the
opposite wow
smart
okay okay okay thank you for
that starting point um okay and i also
wanted to ask about
the prophetic writings especially the
book of daniel and revelation because
they helped i think they helped me in
some way get to
symbolic thinking because um
i i was always interested and passionate
about studying them and
trying to understand them but i was
doing it in a in a kind of a
semiotics way like one-to-one
correlation um but i think they could be
a sort of school of symbolism if you try
to understand them better so
if you have some also some references or
some
some ways to understand them better well
the book of revelation is very very
difficult it's like the most that's why
if you notice i make videos i almost
never talk about revelation
just because it's really though it's
really in terms of symbolism it's
you can see it's like so you can kind of
read it and get a sense
of all the things it's talking about
and let's say the culmination of the
pattern
in the book of revelation but it's too
much
it's like uh it's like i said there's
something about it which is
it it's a it's like taking too much
in and so you you almost need to to be a
saint to really
here's the mystery of the book of
revelation but
i think that if you if you if you kind
of break it down and you look at some
aspects and you look at
for example an image that i reference a
lot
is the the appearance of the heavenly
jerusalem
you know as a culmination of the entire
story
as the coming together of the garden
with the fall you know being brought
together into one image
the idea of the of the garden but also
the wall
which is which is based on the fall
which is the let's say the
the development of technology and and
all the the technical skills that came
through the descendants of cane
when you see that image together of the
tree with the water of life
and then the the glorious wall around it
that's a good image you know
um and and there's there's a lot of
things in there too like this notion of
like death
being thrown into death the idea of of
the
last thing that will die is death that
type of imagery
which is which is bringing us into the
resolution of the whole story right the
resolution of the whole bible story
and so it's it's really all there in
scripture in in
revelation but some of the images are
hard to
uh they're just hard some of them are
hard because
there are some that that do seem to be
pointing to
more specific like sometimes it just
seems to be pointing to more specific
things
um but let's say the image of the
let's say that the images that are
proposed of the throne
and the let's say the alt like for
example the notion that the altar
is the center okay that's a really let
that's an example of something people
don't realize
in revelation you have the altar in the
middle and you have the lamb
on the altar okay and you you have
you know the choirs around that that
altar the choir of angels around the
altar
well that's the reason why we have the
altar
in the church a lot of people say that
the a lot of people say that the church
is based on the old testament
that the structure of the church with
the let's say a holy place
in the middle and then the nave you know
and then the narthex is based on
the the old testament pattern which is
one of the reasons why people some
people want to get rid of it because
they say
you know these things are gone these
things are but that's not it's not based
on the old testament it's based mostly
on revelation
because in the temple the altar is not
in the holy of holies
the altar is outside the altar is in the
outer court
but christianity joins the symbolism of
the ark of the covenant
with the altar which is
which is crazy but which is that's what
christianity is
it's the raising up of christ
on a cross the lifting up of the king
as he's being crucified and so the king
and the crucified one
the altar and the ark are brought
together
are joined together into one it's a
crazy crazy uh
notion and it's and it's really
important if you do believe in
this this the idea that christ brings
together all the opposites and kind of
joins them together in this person
um and so revelation is actually the
the pattern of the church building very
much so
let's say a adjoining of old testament
symbolism with
the symbolism found in revelation that's
what we so
the traditional architecture of the
church is is based on that
um and so that's something you find in
revelation there's a lot of stuff in
there that you'll
the idea also like of the saints under
the altar where the saints are crying
out from all
under the altar in revelation that's why
we put relics under altars
right because it's too it's not saying
that
that it's it and it's people are so
incapable of thinking in
different levels of reality it's not
saying that in revelation it's talking
about a physical alter with
physical saints underneath but what
we're doing is we're manifesting in the
physical world
the patterns which appear in the higher
spheres and so
saint john perceives these patterns
above and so now we replicate those
patterns below
and so what is the living saint let's
say
uh who is uh crying out to god
in the heavenly at the heavenly altar
becomes the
remain the the body of the saint the the
remainder of the saint
who is acting as a kind of foundation
stone
under the physical altar of the church
right and so there's all of these
so much of church architecture um so
much of the the liturgy as well is based
on the book of revelation
so a lot of people it's like some you'll
meet you'll see orthodox priests
who say things like the best way to
understand revelation is
to attend an orthodox liturgy because
that's what's going on
you know um and then you understand like
they're
there are many things in the orthodox
liturgy for example that that are
trying to do no this move of putting the
altar in
the holy holy place there's a lot of
things in the liturgical text
related to revelation that are trying to
show you
the connection and so there's for
example there's a place in the liturgy
where uh we sing the holy holy holy
you know lord of sabbath that you find
in the old testament
of the chair of the cherubs singing that
and then we say
blessed is he who comes in the name of
the lord which is the
which is what they said when christ
entered into jerusalem
and so it's like we both have this call
upon god
and then the recognition of the king on
earth
in the in in christ entering into
jerusalem so it's like this joining of
heaven and earth together
in the person of christ and so that
happens all the time in like
everything that christianity is supposed
to do that's what it's supposed to be
about
so if you want a key to christian art
that's what it should always be should
always be about
about the joining of heaven and earth
and showing how the extremes can meet in
the person of christ
okay um i will i've also in
understood uh the revelation as uh
describing the pattern
pattern for uh the end of
something the end of the world but also
the end of
something and you've mentioned uh
breaking it apart for uh
understanding some symbols there's um uh
this image
uh there's this image of the seven
trumpets uh seven angels and seven trump
seven trumpets and there's the sixth one
uh when he
blows he blows the trumpet all the
things go
upside down so there's like islands and
mountains going into seas and something
like that
and then the seventh angel blows his
trumpet and there's an angel that stands
with one foot uh on the ground and one
foot in the water
and uh i really like that i was thinking
it was
either either jordan pearson or you like
the ground being order and k uh water
being killed or something like that
yeah well that's what that's what it is
and that's referring that's referring
right straight back into genesis it's
not
it's connecting you to genesis which is
the idea of
the you know the the primordial waters
as being tohu
as being the earth as being a primordial
water and then
heaven being order but then you can
bring it down lower right so
at first in in genesis you have heaven
and earth and earth is watery
and then they pull earth out of the
water and then earth becomes
let's say let's say a lower virgin of
heaven
the mountain right so the mountain
becomes a lower version of heaven
and then water below and so standing on
earth and water
becomes akin to connecting heaven and
earth at a lower level you could say you
could say it that way
um and so yeah those those patterns are
definitely referring
straight back into genesis when you read
when you see that in revelation
okay um i only have one
question left it's uh also related to a
personal experience that i have
and i wanted to ask you um what's your
opinion of
mystical experiences um
is there there's something to be uh
sought or something to be um
[Music]
yeah well i can say this way
the the church fathers and the ascetic
fathers and the
you know they always say that you have
to beware of mystical
experiences um
they they'll say that mythical
experiences will happen
like they will happen but you have to be
careful
you have to not confuse
the the the tool or the you know the
lower
rungs on the ladder to where you're
going and so one of the problems that
people have is that they have these
mystical experiences and they think that
that's it like this is it
this is this is i've i i've reached
where i'm supposed to be
um and and and they're wrong and they
can
that mythical experience can become a a
stumbling stone for them actually you
know and so you have to be very careful
and be very
um happy very discerning and not attach
yourself to those mystical experiences
but there's nothing i mean mystical
experiences happen of course and they
happen to
to the saints and they happen to the
aesthetics and they can happen to normal
people you can have a mystical
i mean it also depends what you mean
like how high
of a you can have a mystical experiences
mystical experience while
drinking a glass of water it just really
just depends on
how how deep and profound that mystical
experience is it
is let's say
to it is possible it seems for for
saints to live completely in that moment
of
pure insight where where they they they
they're
completely connected you know and for
most of us it's a glimpse and a moment
and
then it's fleeting and it goes away and
then we when we go on you know
i don't it's like i i don't know it's
hard because i i don't totally
i would say if you brought something
back from that
then great like that's wonderful and if
and if it's made you
you know if it's it's given you some
insight on the nature of things on god
and especially on your you know
if it was a motor for you to be more
involved in your life and in your
relationships and in your
your spiritual quest then that's awesome
you know
that's great i would say that's probably
ultimately
the best okay
yeah okay um
and that's it for me all right well it
was a lot of fun to
to talk to radu thank you i hope i hope
what i said was a little useful i'm
sorry if i sometimes i get into
i can become fall into rant mode and
hopefully i didn't do that too much this
time
okay that's okay i hope
[Music]
it was really useful for me and uh i
hope that
triggers some um some ideas to youtube
some insight not too much inside though
so tell me if you post this to give me
send me a link or tell me
when you post it sure sure all right
it's good to talk to you thank you